[Applause]
getting an abortion is not easy making
that decision is not easy it's not
something people do lightly it's not
something that you can just do it it is
a hard awful decision that people make
celebrities are speaking out in response
to news that the supreme court could
potentially overturn roe v wade a
landmark decision made by the u.s
supreme court in 1973
that legalized abortion on a national
scale
women when they decide
something is not right for them they're
going to take it into their own hands on
tuesday whoopi goldberg spoke
passionately on the view about her
thoughts on the draft opinion that was
leaked monday from the supreme court
detailing plans to overturn abortion
rights we got tired of tripping over
women in bathrooms public bathrooms who
were giving themselves abortions because
there was nowhere safe nowhere clean
nowhere to go
this law
came about because people wanted people
to have somewhere safe and somewhere
clean it has nothing to do with your
religion this is not a religious issue
this is a human issue whoopi stressed
her point by emphasizing how getting an
abortion is not a decision most women
take lightly it's not something that you
can just do it it is a hard awful
decision and the talk show host gave
this suggestion to those who see it
differently if you don't have the
wherewithal to understand that to start
this conversation with i know how hard
this must be for you if you're starting
it by telling me i'm going to burn in
hell then you're not looking out for me
as a human being whether i subscribe to
your religion or not and that is not
okay after the report was released
showing a draft of justice samuel
alito's majority opinion overturning roe
v wade protesters hit the streets monday
night and on tuesday amy schumer being
one of them she gave her followers a
call to action on instagram the actress
shared this post that reads quote to the
streets she captioned it quote give us
our dignity or we will take it this is
why we fight the 40 year old also shared
this photo of herself along with other
women during tuesday's mass protest that
took place across the country she
captioned it quote bans off our bodies
it's like we're doing it together
another famous face who joined the mass
protest tuesday is model emily
ratakowski she shared this photo on
instagram with her infant son on her
shoulder and in the back you see a sign
that reads abortion is a human right
hillary clinton responded to news of the
leaked opinion by tweeting in part quote
not surprising but still outrageous
this decision is a direct assault on the
dignity rights and lives of women not to
mention decades of settled law president
joe biden released a statement that
reads in part quote we do not know
whether this draft is genuine or whether
it reflects the final decision of the
court he adds quote i believe that a
woman's right to choose is fundamental
roe has been the law of the land for
almost 50 years and basic fairness and
the stability of our law demand and not
to be overturned barack obama echoed
that sentiment in a statement he
released on behalf of himself and
michelle obama that reads quote if the
supreme court ultimately decides to
overturn the landmark case of roe v wade
then it will not only reverse nearly 50
years of precedent it will regulate the
most intensely personal decision someone
can make to the whims of politicians and
ideologues he adds quote the
consequences of this decision would be a
blow not just to women but to all of us
who believe that in a free society there
are limits to how much the government
can encroach on our personal lives
you